même très mal d longevilles mont d'or
dans le jura et royaliste et nous
commandent un micro trottoir ce qui
n'est pas incompatible pourquoi le
serait ce dans un pays si forte
tradition monarchique nous écrit-elle je
m'étonne parfois d'une méconnaissance
aussi grande de notre histoire de france
que les français vraiment ont la mémoire
courte
mieux vaut en rire ajoute ces dames avec
philosophie et c'est pourquoi j'aimerais
que gérard pas bio et constater de visu
l'étendue de notre méconnaissance sur le
sujet aussitôt écrit aussitôt fait
régulièrement jacques chirac fait porter
le chapeau aux attentes de faire porter
le chapeau habité rend l inverse
qu'est ce que vous en pensez écoutez
c'est pas moi je me serais bien
mitterrand avec à chapeau oui c'est va
très bien et chirac
pourquoi pas avec un à une casquette oui
c'est va bien mais je trouve qu'il est
bien le style pour porter ça voyez vous
ce qu'on appelle l' odeur de sainteté
monsieur bah c'est reconnaître une femme
qui est enceinte par son odeur
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais le
gens pensent que toute façon même à
l'oeil je veux dire il n'y a pas de
problème on le voit même avant que ça
sens je dirais salle et vous toujours
monsieur sur quel pied danser le tango
par le pied droit 1 passe à dhoble le
faut car les pieds en même temps je peux
faire une démonstration si vous voulez
la wii c'est pas difficile
on y va tout seul vous voyez c'est moi
je suis pas très doué mois pour la 11è
de piloter oui oui mais pourquoi vous
rillieux c'est une question qui surprend
quand même dans la rue et surtout de ce
temps là et pourquoi ça paraît évident
que d'être qu'il était c'est à dire ma
cassoulet je vous dise moi tout le monde
je pense que tout le monde est culotté
le sens là c'est normal
culotté
je pensais quand même trouver quelqu'un
dans la rue ce matin qui me font ce
genre de questions c'est à dire basket
vous pilotez je pense que vous y êtes
que tout le monde y est moi je le
prouverai pas non plus à propos de nana
mouskouri que vous connaissez j'aimerais
vous parler du velouté de savoie
j'en ai déjà mangé il s'agit de ce fait
avec de la crème et des champignons qui
sont sans doute de la savoie doit bien
entendu parler du van houtte est savoie
nana mouskouri
oui et qu'est ce que c'est je voulais
dire c'est un potage c'est quand on n'a
pas de chance qu'on est dans de beaux
draps
ah bon dans de beaux draps oui mais moi
je préfère pas avoir de chance est dans
de beaux draps que d'être dans la dans
la crotte et que deux sous les ponts je
préfère encore être dans des draps de
soie puis pour voir de chances que
pensez vous des gens qui passent la main
madame j'aime pas vous aimez pas quoi je
n'aime pas ça même dans le dos ou sur le
bras j'aime pas qu'on me tripote donc si
vous rencontrez quelqu'un qui passe la
main moi je refais une gifle que pensez
vous madame des gens qui font chou blanc
mais ces questions de bien digérer mais
les choux et les choux-fleurs
c'est à dire c'est à dire ces deux
légumes là principalement ça vous arrive
au bout de faire chou blanc quelques
francs à chaque fois que je fais cuire
ces deux légumes et comment faites vous
alors bien je les ai bouillante
je les plonge dans l'eau bouillante et
ensuite je les ai gouttes et je les aime
a fait cuire normalement voyez-vous ce
qu'on appelle les feux de la rampe
monsieur oui qu'est-ce que c'est cadeau
la malle au face à face de glisser sur
la rampe
donc elle que ça vous arrive des fois ça
m'arrivait oui anne est un gamin
le général de gaulle vous connaissez
vous savez qu'il a connu un moment donné
la traversée du désert savait également
ce qu'elle a traversée du désert oui
parce que c'est un désert que vous mais
plusieurs motos qui risquent leur vie et
puis
genre c'est le bon courage quand même
parce que c'est pas évident faire ça
c'est ya pas mal d'accidents ni des
motos qui risquent leur vie et général
de gaulle dans tout ça la traversée du
désert pouvoir qu'est ce que c'est la
traversée du désert
c'est un dessert s'asseyait qui savent
et bien oui il ya que du sade et puis
beaucoup trop niveau de sa est pire dans
la vie du général de gand enfin moi
disons un peu près parce que moi il a
quand même encouragé les personnes pour
faire ça déjà parce que je ne
connaîtrais pas beaucoup d'efforts et à
des chats pour le général de gaulle
j'avais entendu parler dakar du général
de gaulle et enthousiaste traversée du
désert oui c'est pareil dakar et puis
j'adore le général de gaulle qu'est ce
qu'il aurait fallu ben je crois qu'il a
essayé de faire la même chose qu'on a
essayé de participer au niveau des
pilotes
il faisait quoi lui à l'huile et encres
de présenter comment ça se passait au
déroulement dans un hélicoptère
le général de gaulle général et groupe
paris dakar c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
traversée du désert
oui voilà